[Music]
imagine
winning the lotto and then having to
forfeit it because
the mail the usps lost your ticket
wait what how
that happened to this woman in florida
damn what
she turned it in and then they lasted it
so
she couldn't go to the lotto office in
person because of corona
wow so she mailed it in thinking that
that
like she's certified mailed it in did
she take a picture
to see this is my ticket [ __ ] oh
she probably didn't huh
i don't know she didn't think it through
you can photoshop that now and she
didn't get the one with insurance
yes she did so she she got the certified
isn't that the certified one no it's
different once i can certify using the
signature
one you can like ensure the value of
what's going on the usps
is lacking i'm insuring this for 30
million
yeah yeah how do you even lose a ticket
that's like that
i know right so she like i said so she
instead of dropping it in the mail in
like the drop in box at the lottery
place
she ended up sending it through
certified mail and then
she was a second chance lotto winner so
it wasn't like the initial thing like
she ended up like
signing up whatever the second chance
lotto that's how she won
okay uh what's second chance so like if
you try if you get a scratch off ticket
and you didn't
you didn't win at all you could go
online and you can type in
whatever you need to type in and then
you're you're pulled in for a second
chance oh
yeah how far away was a lotto office i
don't know yeah
i think i would have if i ever win i'm
dropping it off by myself dude
it's like let's say it's like a 30
million dollar lot oh my god
why would you let that thing go because
she thought certified male would be
safer
no [ __ ] the postal office be [ __ ] up
if i got 30 million the minute i see the
postman pull up in front of my house
i'm gonna point a gun at him we're going
we're [ __ ] going right now we're
gonna mail this [ __ ] right now
that's what i'm gonna do and you gotta
watch it every step yep well i mean you
could
just drop it off yourself at that point
but i wanna mail it still so you're
gonna put it so i'm gonna make sure he
drives it
but they still have to stab it yeah so
so then
her checking information it shows that
the ticket arrived at 7
12 a.m on august 12th at the tallahassee
post office
but then we don't know what happened to
the ticket after that
yeah so i would go to [ __ ]
tallahassee i'm like i'm gonna [ __ ]
look
in every crevice of this [ __ ]
until you
and me find it how much was the winning
ticket i didn't want to tell you yet
okay okay i'll wait for it then because
then i feel like i'll change your
don't tell me it's twelve dollars your
mood on all this i'm not gonna tell you
a dollar is a dollar
but it's like nine bucks i'll fight for
free ticket
it's the principal when you win the free
ticket you want another scratcher you're
a third chance winner
but yeah so then that's when uh
they were saying like listen oh oh
because
because of the fact that she didn't get
her ticket to the main headquarters in
tallahassee
by the date that she needed to submit it
which is a seven day
period ah she's lazy well because of
this
so then they said like we didn't receive
a ticket so then it went off to the
second
person in line that won so then they got
the
the winnings because the usps didn't
[ __ ] up on them huh no and then the
second guy happened to be an employee at
usps
oh conspiracy oh yeah so then but they
did say
like okay listen we know this is very
rare
it doesn't happen you say you did mail
it in before the deadline
if you if somehow this ticket arrives at
our office and it's stamped with the
date
before the the the due date then we'll
honor it and we'll
we'll give you your winner oh that's
dope you're 500.
it's 500. no oh double it
oh i mean it's
still annoying but hey hey hey not
everyone's balling like you tim a
thousand dollars
pardon me
you could buy a house in tennessee for a
thousand dollars
imagine no she did say that for her it
was like winning a [ __ ] ton of money
because she
it's free money dude i know it's just a
thousand dollars to me
is enough to be pissed like okay if it
was like
20 bucks right i'm just like i'd still
be pissed if i didn't get a 20
yeah joe well this guy's a different
story he he'd he'd be a billionaire and
still get pissed if it's twenty dollars
true right
yeah twenty bucks what's the minimum of
amount that you would care
there's no minimum amount so one penny
was owed to you and you'd be
pissed by principal yes but i wouldn't
go out of my way to like
spend more than a year so no energy so
that's what i mean like what what is
like the bare minimum that you would
spend energy to retrieve it i would do
it for a thousand
yeah i've driven to costco to return
like bad fruit
oh my god a thousand what the [ __ ] are
you no that's what i'm saying like i
would definitely do it for less
holy [ __ ] i mean i was gonna go through
it how much was that fruit you're crazy
six bucks
that's [ __ ] up costco gave you rotten
fruit no like nah that's on you bro if
you chose the wrong watermelon that's a
gamble we all take you can't you can't
blame i never
returned fruit yeah because you're too
rich
i feel like if you buy a like a box of
fruit and the shit's [ __ ] up like
little like you know
uh apples or some [ __ ] then you could
return it watermelon we all agree that
it's a gamble
i didn't know you could return fruit yes
you can return anything you can
the minute if i if i saw fruit and i was
pissed i'm like oh what the [ __ ]
the minute that i even visualized
costco's parking lot i'm like nah i'm
gonna
i didn't know either because we ordered
some like in the beginning the pandemic
and i was really afraid to like step
foot outside my house i got instacart
groceries like i did it like twice i
think
and both times whenever we ordered
anything fresh
that the it's bad right it's always
horrible
like so it's it's an inedible they don't
do a good job picking
no no better look every time i instacart
watermelons their their choices are on
you just jinxed yourself
i don't i hope i hope not i hope not man
maybe you're just getting it
it was watermelon seasons no no because
me and chia whenever we try to go look
for some watermelons and we we look at
all the we google all the tips we look
for the [ __ ] big ass
oh you're trying too hard all that [ __ ]
you need the ones
with the scars it has to look like a
pirate do we do all that [ __ ] we look
for all that [ __ ] we never get a good
we never get a good one but then
whenever we instacart it we bust that
[ __ ] open it's like oh you have to not
care so much you just have to be like
whatever impossible you're too thirsty
for it and then you get it and you're
just like
it's the bad box of watermelon
but yeah don't i mean you got lucky
because
this [ __ ] you guys would be very proud
of me when i was in vegas i only gambled
one dollar one dollar i stepped into so
many casinos and i did not play but you
did for a dollar
at the airport not the goal oh ty and i
was at a casino over the
uh a couple days ago i didn't play
anything wow but how many strip clubs
did you go to
zero i don't go to strip clubs you don't
i only go when i go with people and i
like to pay for their lap dances
yeah aren't they close probably yeah
probably they did big dance with masks
right yeah there's drive-through strip
clubs right yeah you drive by and
they're on the poles that's lame it's
pretty lame
you did it no but i seen it yeah how do
you make money if you just drive by
you throw the money yeah i don't think
it's when you swipe your credit card on
the square
hole so it's like a drive-through and
then it's like a show or something it's
like a restaurant thing
i don't know interesting yeah it's
pretty weird mm-hmm
um went to get some condoms the other
day and i think i walked into a gay
brothel
a gay brother at the right age no it's
like a uh
there's a brothel i ride it because i
was i was looking for like a sex shop
near
our uh one of our shops and then
i i found one in the area and then i i
walked in
and it was like well first of all you go
in and it's like
there's no women was that the first one
but you walk in and
it's a ton of dvds and stuff on the wall
and whatever
and then when you look at the register
and there's a huge poster
of a guy like this and another guy on
top of him and his dick is in his
butthole oh yeah oh one of those posters
yeah um i mean it's got things for women
and all that and then uh
equal opportunity yeah and then um a guy
walks out so there's like video rooms
like there's like
doors where you can go and watch
i guess videos and [ __ ] jack off or
whatever right and then a guy
is a a man comes out and he has uh
these he has these boots that go up to
his thigh and it's all like whatever
but then like in super super short
shorts but then from like
the shirt up it's like different it's
it's they don't look like a street
walker it's just like a t-shirt
and then like it's a dude right with the
mask on
and i don't know the mask yeah cause
we're inside the store we have to wear
them i have to
oh [ __ ] because you said a sex shop i
was thinking like a sex type of mask
i was thinking imagine if they're like
i'm not sort of
i'm just going to wear a ball gag yeah
that's what i like so he was coming out
he bought like some lube and then he
went back into the thing oh
and then um i was like wait what is
going on here right
then you heard two dudes harmonizing so
i can see
construction guys and like truck driver
guys and all them going
it's like the ymca in and out of these
doors
and i'm like oh my god dude i think this
is like a
secret brothel hmm above all you tried
going
bro no i didn't i didn't ask i was just
like
and i thought it was a a lady behind the
counter
and it wasn't like at first i thought
like from the back you know and then
um it was just it was just very gender
neutral is what i should say like i
don't know it's i couldn't tell
right so i didn't want to judge what
they were i was just kind of like
whoa okay so i walked into a place
i think this is like an underground like
illegal
like prostitution place but they
hide that their video sex store what if
it was just an escape room
or what if they had well i guess other
people never wanted to escape you know
what i mean like
damn depends on who you're asking so
you're thinking that people are
people that are walking into these rooms
are having sex with themselves like with
each other
or do you think there's like i think
there's other people
and i saw one of the workers the sex
workers
yeah i always felt like most like when
you see those video stores or those
adult video stores like
that there's secret rooms in the back
where people you know like glory holes
and [ __ ]
yeah but i thought that was a porno like
the glory hole porno i didn't think that
it really
went down like he's real bro would you
be down and stick your dick in a glory
hole if i knew who was on the other side
no if you didn't
it's just like you show up you see it no
i'm too scared
yeah scared of the st you're allowed to
first look through the glory hole
that's how cameron diaz got her eye
poked yeah the dick what
oh the sweetest thing but even in real
life nothing
in the movie it was pretty it was pretty
scary though
i went in and i was like this is not
what i expected did they anyone lick
their lips at you
no dude it was like business as usual
everyone it was just normal you know
like they're just like
oh what do you need you need help
whatever all right
and then that was it and everything was
hella casual you didn't you didn't know
like the right signals and [ __ ]
i just saw a lot of truck drivers
construction workers
got a lot of guys walking in and out of
those places man
and i was like wow people still buy dvds
that's what i'm saying dude they were
dusty old dvds
i don't think that's what they were
there for it's a front super friend yeah
they had like
five dildos and like a ball gag and it
looked so empty
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you